[Music]
caitlin is with us caitlin's in memphis
hi caitlin welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and ken how are you guys good
what's up
great so i'm 23 years old i just
graduated with my master's on april 30th
congratulations
awesome
thank you in cyber security oh wow
cha-ching yeah yeah
you hear that sound that you hear that
printing press sound in the background
folks that's money
yeah she knows it too that's the laugh
of uh you're right
good for you so
thank you so my mother um informed me
that um she has zero save for retirement
and expects me to
take care of her during her retirement
years
um obviously i don't want to abandon my
mother so how can i best prepare myself
to take care of her when that time comes
you're 23.
how old is your mother
she is 46 sir
okay
so what part of her childhood trauma
has damaged her psychologically to make
this ridiculous butt statement
that i am not sure
do you agree that that's absolutely
ludicrous for a 46 year old to put on a
23 year old that you're going to have to
take care of me someday when you've got
20 more years to work you ought to be
taking care of yourself
when you put it that way sure um
but
i do love my mother that's not a
question of loving your mother it's not
a question of honoring your mother
your mother's misbehaving
does she work now does she have any type
of career or job or there's some type of
challenge she's dealing with that makes
her put this on you what's what's the
back story
she does work um she's a secretary and
making around 30k year
i just think it's uh it's a matter of um
not knowing
how to get to
since she hasn't saved up to this point
i think it's a matter of not knowing
when this how to start
or
you know that type of thing was this a
flippant comment or you think she
seriously expects you to just to write
her checks when she retires because
she's worked her whole life and didn't
bother
i think it's 100 serious okay okay all
right
well there's two or three issues going
on okay issue number one is the answer
to your question is how do you help
anyone financially you first have to put
your own oxygen mask on meaning that you
can't help people if you're broke so you
need to become wealthy and you're going
to do that you're going to be making a
lot of money and you're going to follow
the baby steps that we teach and you're
going to stay out of debt and you're
going to invest and save and you're
going to be a multi-millionaire
by the time you're 40.
okay
and so you'll be able to write her
checks
that does not mean you should but
mathematically you would be able to if
you follow that do you agree with that
yes sir okay then the next part of the
question for me is
um how do we honor
the office
of motherhood
in other words the bible says honor your
father and mother it does not say buy
them cocaine
if they are a cocaine addict
that is not honoring them
and so we don't the bible's not
suggesting that by honoring your parents
you participate in their misbehavior
and for a 46 year old to plan on
retiring broke and be taken care of by
their children is misbehavior in the
american culture
now in some cultures it would not be but
in north america in memphis tennessee
that's misbehavior
you follow me
yes sir so how can we help mom when mom
is engaged in
misbehavior behavior that's
inappropriate
uh and so what i would do is this i i
would say hey mom i'm gonna go through
this class because i'm gonna start
making a lot of money call financial
peace university to learn how to handle
money and man i really want you to go
with me
would you go with me mom
and i'll pay for it
and let's get her in this class and
teach her how to handle money
and let's get her believing having some
hope that she actually could have the
dignity of controlling her own
destination without depending upon her
daughter because i got to tell you i
don't know what kind of person it is
that actually feels okay about
themselves
when
they are
planning to fail
and dump it on their own kids
i don't think she feels good about
herself
when she says that
or she does if she does then somebody
needs to bust her
and we can take care of either one we
can help her by busting her or we can
help her that's right and caitlyn
having some hope again and going okay
hey let's take this 32 000 let's
motivate you to get that income up let's
motivate you to get your budget going
and start saving because she honestly
should be able to take care of herself
and i can show her how and i will show
her how and i'll pay for it yeah caitlyn
what's missing here is your mom simply
doesn't know that's what you said
earlier in the call she just doesn't
know
and so if you could take her to that
class and then begin to cast a vision
for her to show her at the age of 46 if
she puts away this amount of money per
year over the next 20 years where she
can get to she just needs to see some
vision as well so don't just take her to
the class and encourage her show her but
begin to take that knowledge that dave's
going to teach in that class and show
her how to see
what she could actually do a lot of
times dave ignorance is debilitating
yeah you don't know and so you become
hopeless and then you do uh stupid stuff
like you know dump this on your 23 year
old kid yeah it's just absurd so
um
i i want you to hear i'm i'm uh
the main thing i want you to come away
from this conversation with caitlyn
is the courage to say
mom you are responsible for you i'm
don't need to be
and no i don't accept this assignment
and i do love you and oh by the way this
woman right here she could be a travel
agent for guilt trips sometimes can't
she
yes sir yeah and so don't don't don't
cash the ticket in on the guilt trip
just go yeah
i'm one of four kids who
like not to
you know
throw dirt on my siblings but i'm the
one who quote unquote made it out and
actually did something yeah with my life
yeah you're gonna cause you're gonna go
big your income's gonna be more than
your brothers and sisters put together
oh yes sir i'm starting with 100k yeah
yeah and you're going and you're going
to 200 and then i blink in your world if
you're smart as i think you are and
caitlin but that does not mean you have
to take care of everybody that won't
take care of themselves right
that is not a moral obligation on your
part
and i want to set you free from that
then if you choose to turn around once
you're emotionally free from this toxic
argument this toxic mandate that's
coming at you once you're emotionally
free from that if you still choose to
come back as a position of strength when
you don't have to but even though i
don't have to i want to i'm still going
to be kind and i'm going to help some
people that didn't that are in a mess
then that's fine
that's fine but i don't want you signing
up at 23 years old for a 46 year old
babysitting job that's just ridiculous
that's right and caitlyn i would also
tell you if you're not careful there's
an emotional trap in this relationship
and here's the trap
mom puts the pressure on you to do this
you love your mom you don't want to
disappoint mom so here's what happens
you do something that inherently you
know you shouldn't have to do
and in trying to please your mom you end
up resenting your mom yep and what dave
is telling you to do is
uh you need to be okay disappointing mom
but in disappointing her hopefully
pointing her to a better future
and then in the end you won't resent her
and so i would always rather disappoint
a family member or friend
than i would resent them because see the
disappointment is on her side the
resentment will stay with you the rest
of your life and so you got to be
careful of the emotional trap here
here's the last part of the story and
then we're basically i want you to hold
on kelly's going to sign you and your
mom up for financial peace university
i'm going to pay for it i want you guys
to go to the class okay we want to help
you fix this problem but here's the last
part
when you meet a guy
if he's a really good guy
and he wants to be your husband and you
want to be his wife
and you fall in love
he's not gonna like this deal
he's not gonna like this obligation that
comes
with this deal
i've met this great gal but
she insists on taking care of her mother
who won't take care of herself
that's
how can i say this highly unattractive
that's a good way of saying it there you
go okay